يعني حضرتك تفضلت بكلمه مهمه في البدايه
انه
عبد المجيد الشرفي الاسلام متعدد نصر ابو
زيد في مفهوم النص قال كده قال قولوا لنا
اي اسلام تريدون اسلام المعتزله اسلام
السنه اسلام الخوارج اسلام الجهاد اسلام
الشيعه اي اسلام انت عاوزينه ده هذا النص
اعطته لطالب قلت له رد قول الاسلام لم
يستطع باحث مخلص دراسات عليا يعني انا كما
قلت لك نحن الادوات مفقوده المناهج
التعليميه تعيد الان الدراسات في العالم
كله في الجامعات الغربيه بتقوم على ان كيف
تنقط
المعلومات بين اصابعك انت الان غير زمان
زي ما احنا ممكن نقعد نقلب في الكتب اسبوع
10 ايام وشهر والشهر عشان تحصل على معلومه
الان تفتح جوجل اي معلومه انت عايزها تجيء
لك امال احنا محتاجين ايه دلوقت محتاجين
العقل الناقد مش الكمي نحن عاوزين باللغه
الفلسفيه عاوزين الكيفي كيف تفكر في هذا
المنقول الذي امامك كيف تفكر في هذا
التراث وانا ليا كلمه شهيره اقول ان لم
نحكم الفكر والاصول الكليه ستلعب بنا
الكتب الكتب مليئه بالمتناقضات ومليئه
بالاراء الشاذه ومريا بالاراء التي لا
يتقبلها